mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
cette crise sera longue et aura des
conséquences majeures
sur l'avenir de l'europe mais pour
autant c'est bien le droit à la paix et
la démocratie qui devront à la fin en
sortir vainqueur
nous assistons
au premier acte n'est pas terminée il
fait évidemment
sans surprise apparaître le délit de
déséquilibre des forces en présence mais
aussi mais aussi le courage admirable du
peuple ukrainien et la mobilisation
inédite
de la communauté internationale
nous avons toujours été clairs et nos
amis ukrainiens l'ont d'emblée compris
un pays comme la france
ne peut recourir à la force que si elle
est directement attaqués ou dans le
cadre des systèmes d' allianz dont elle
fait partie
l'alliance atlantique dont nous sommes
membres et une alliance défensive
elle se défend lorsque l'un de ses
membres est agressée et l'ukraine n'est
pas membre de l'otan
mais il n'y a aucun doute
que nous serions amenés à nous engager
militairement dans la protection de nos
alliés de l'europe de l'est si le
conflit devait connaître d'autres
extensions delà du territoire ukrainien
dans les pays membres de l'alliance le
présent la république a d'ores et déjà
décidé de renforcer notre participation
dispositif de l'otage dans les pays
baltes en pologne et en roumanie
tout en restant engagé
dans l'approfondissement de l'europe de
la défense
la france tient sa place de membre actif
solidaire est impliqué dans l'alliance
atlantique à ce titre
je rappelle que nos forces armées
participent sans interruption depuis
plusieurs années à la réassurance de nos
alliés orientaux notamment dans les pays
baltes où notre engagement va se
poursuivre
à terre et dans les airs nous allons
également prendre la tête en tant que
nation cadre d'un bataillon
multinational qui va se déployer cette
semaine madame la ministre en roumanie
tout cela mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
nous le faisons parce que nous le devons
nous le faisons aussi parce que nous le
pouvons et nous le pouvons en large part
je le rappelle à la représentation
nationale et par-delà à l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens parce que nous avons su
parce que le président de la république
a su donner depuis 2019 une infection
forte aux moyens affectés à notre
défense nationale
[Musique]